the secularism of the world actually
recently the former Minister of
Education in France admitted the ICT
which is secularism is actually a form
of religion so it's very interesting
because coming from them you know they
they are now admitting that the ideology
behind secularism is actually a system
of belief so what is a religion if not a
system of belief Wow so when people say
we don't want more religion we want
secularism well guess what you are into
a system of belief Salam alaikum guys
we're here with Julian from France and
we're continuing on getting little
snippets of his story so now that you've
accepted Islam we were talking about
Jesus it's very interesting he was
mentioning that because the fact of the
matter is that Jesus was not his name
the language the English language did
not exist but there was a Christian
author who wrote on this they did a
documentary The Lost years of Jesus and
he concludes that Issa was his name yes
and this is what the most are
interviewing scholars from Nepal in in
India Malaya because he sought to leave
his community for for many years because
it was his journey so he preached the
oneness of Allah in many many places
that's why most places I've recorded in
the holy book that someone holy came and
his name was Issa at the same time but
we know it was you know
in the world you know so it's very easy
to connect the dots actually yeah that
that's that's the the commonalities that
we have that for most Christians to know
and this is what most Christians they
actually many reject the Trinity that
when you ask Christians do you believe
Jesus was God or sent by God the
majority when they think about say yeah
I believe he was sent by God we recently
had a theologian a Bible scholar in
Chicago she was a blind lady and in her
eyes but not her heart and she said she
struggled with this the attention that's
given to Jesus instead of God Almighty
but now you want french citizen born
pure French or from France and now it's
barely a secular country huh yeah in one
generation my grandparents used to go to
church now it became but we have to
understand this didn't happen just by
coincidence
it was orchestrated the secularism of
the world actually recently the former
Minister of Education in France admitted
the Lai City which is secularism is
actually a form of religion so it's very
interesting because coming from them you
know they they are now admitting that
the ideology behind secularism is
actually a system of belief so what is a
religion if not a system of belief Wow
so when people say we don't want more
religion we want secularism well guess
what you are into a system of belief but
now you fought through all of that and
you ended up accepting Islam but some of
the commonalities were Christian when we
make this distinction that yeah we
believe in Jesus is a mighty messenger
we love him we revere him it's a part of
the articles of faith to believe in the
messengers Jesus being one of the
greatest messengers Christians and even
Jews you know and other people in
humanity this this makes sense you know
because the Jewish view is why they
reject Jesus most of the time is because
of the Christian view of Jesus
right but the Islamic Phoenix to write
the Islamic view is that he was like
Moses he was like Abraham who's like all
the preceding messengers that came with
the same simple message worship the one
God the one creator there's no deity
worthy of worship except the one who
created you so this love that we have
with Jesus that message people don't
know about it have you noticed that
what's your take on that like when you
talk to Christians and you tell them
this well of course unaware of this
because we haven't studied the the topic
and they just took that's why the I was
very bothered by this blind faith
because Islam is not a blind faith is a
religion of reasoning is a religion of
knowledge so I can't gamble my life my
afterlife in paradise for blind faith
you know so I really decided to study
and and you know this is a very big
decision I made in my life but changed
my life so the way I see Christians now
is they they just take it from parents
of an Australian especially the Catholic
they have abandoned about the Bible the
Catholic and the Catholic who are
watching me they know they are not
reading the Bible and this is why the
Protestant came in because Protestant
they refused the fact that the Bible was
only read by the priests but at the end
of the day of our interpretation is
wrong as well you know so it's all about
trying to encourage Christians to read
the Koran so they can see you know that
the true reality of who Jesus was truly
an enchilada they would be guided as
well there's a whole chapter named after
his blessed mother who Muslim women
emulate by wearing what's called the
hijab and she word also so there's so
many of these gems of wisdom there's so
much in there that you definitely relate
to but you got to give it a try read the
Quran continue to tune in only here at
the Deen show so we can bring you more
of his story and others we're here in
Spain with a Frenchman
in a Bosnian American Salaam alaikum